salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je
voulais faire une vidéo pour donner mon
opinion sur les droites conservatrices
les droites au pluriel qui en france
prennent plus ou moins partie pour la
russie dans le conflit qui l'oppose à
l'ukraine pour ce faire je vais vous
lire un texte que j'ai près écrit et
j'ai donc simplement vous dire tout
simplement parce que je pense que si je
disais les choses telles que je les
pense comme ça au fil de l'eau face
caméra je risquerais d'être un petit peu
trop sanglant
bref c'est parti
sans être natif de la droite je suis où
j'étais je ne sais pas trop pour l'union
des droites vu l'état du pays fut des
problèmes liés à l'immigration à la
délinquance etc je pense que c'est
indispensable pour éviter une
balkanisation de notre pays à terme pour
cela j'ai fait pas mal de compromis
voire avaler pas mal de couleuvres
j'accepte l'union des droites qui
implique une alliance avec des cathos
tradi alors que je suis farouchement
athée j'accepte une alliance avec des
souverainistes qui ces derniers temps
crié à la dictature sanitaires pour
quelques mesures d'urgence passagère je
me dis que ça leur passera j'accepte
l'alliance avec des gens ou passé
trouble à l'ultra droite mais là avec la
guerre en ukraine quelque part la coupe
est pleine peut-être pas plein au point
de renoncer à cette alliance met plein
au point de mettre les choses sur la
table il à vis de ceux qui dans mon camp
ne s'engage pas pleinement pour
l'ukraine voire même prennent fait et
cause pour la russie vous souverainiste
nationaliste conservateur patriotes
droitards de toutes obédiences vous
voulez vous prétendez défendre la france
l'occident ses valeurs sa souveraineté
son existence en tant qu entité
culturelle spécifique cet occident de
culture judéo chrétienne et de racines
gréco romaine or votre positionnement
dans le conflit russie ukraine dit tout
le contraire vos éloges à la russie
poutinienne depuis des années et dont il
restera encore longtemps des traces sur
internet malgré les revirements de
certains montrent qu'au fond vous
détestez l'occident le conflit russo
ukrainien est et sera pour les droits de
conservatrice ce que le venezuela a été
à mélenchon en 2010 est un bourbier
électorale en même temps qu'un
formidable révélateur de vaud fondements
idéologiques la défense du venezuela
chavez avait montré que mélenchon était
temps démocrates pour peu qu'on lui
parle d'égalité de socialisme d'anti
impérialisme et d'anti américanisme en
2022 le positionnement pro poutine
montre que les droites conservatrices du
moins que leur sphère militantes sont
fascinés par l'autoritarisme les
dirigeant à poigne qui n'hésite pas à
museler l'opposition quand ce n'est pas
à écraser les libertés tout le contraire
de l'histoire de l'occident sur les
trois derniers siècles qui ont été une
marche vers la liberté l'autonomie
individuelle et l'état de droit votre
nationalisme votre patriotisme à la
sauce poutine ne sont pas un amour du
peuple mais un amour du pouvoir sur le
peuple les ukrainiens nous montre ce que
sont un vrai patriotisme un vrai
nationalisme défendre sa terre son
identité défendre la possibilité de
choisir son destin collectivement entre
l'est et l'ouest quitte à devoir se
battre contre un ennemi bien plus
puissant que lui et que des gens de
cette trempe choisissent l'occident est
un honneur pour nous les ukrainiens se
bat pour l'occident pas pour le sauver
mais pour l'intégrer
car oui pendant que vous adulez le
régimes à poigne de moscou qui se
transforme au pas de course en dictature
pure et simple à l'occasion de ce
conflit des peuples issus de la sphère
d'influencé culturelle russe se tourner
vers notre blog culturel occidental ils
veulent adhérer à l'otan à l'union
européenne les institutions certes
critiquable une fois qu'on les voie de
l'intérieur l'otan est trop inféodées
aux desiderata américaine et l'union
européenne est une usine à gaz
antidémocratique rempli de lobby mais
néanmoins ce sont des institutions
occidentales porteuse de promesses pour
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur la liberté
la sécurité la paix et surtout une
certaine idée de la civilisation juste
que des pays culturellement et
géographiquement liés à la russie se
tourner vers cet occident devrions tous
le considérer comme une victoire
culturelle et comme une preuve de notre
supériorité morale même décadent même à
l'agonie moralement et spirituellement
même mourant démographiquement même à la
dérive économiquement notre civilisation
ouest européenne attire encore
ce tropisme pour l'autoritarisme vous
allez le payer dans les urnes les
militants adhèrent souvent en bloc un
ensemble de croyances disparates les
électeurs eux sont plus rationnels et
s'ils adhèrent à votre constat sur
l'insécurité l'immigration le déclin de
la civilité de la culture sur
l'ensauvagement il n'est pas dit qu'ils
adhèrent à l'ensemble de votre bloc de
croyance et surtout à votre vision
internationale on peut vouloir la fin de
l'immigration massive et de l'insécurité
sans être fasciné par les dirigeants
adepte des coups de menton cette
fascination pour l'autoritarisme vous
risquez de la payer prochainement quand
poutine va se décider à transformer
l'ukraine résistante en nouvelles
tchétchénie quand il la transformera en
champ de ruines rempli de cadavres et
que les images arriveront sur nos écrans
il vous sera alors difficile d'expliquer
vos positions pro poutine depuis 20 ans
vos citations élogieuses vos photos avec
le fou du kremlin vous ressortir tout
comme va ressortir la lâcheté de
certains eurodéputés qui ont voté contre
l'aide à l'ukraine alors même que la
guerre était déclarée vous pouvez avoir
retournez votre veste en catastrophe
jouer les pacifistes nous dire il faut
négocier faire de la diplomatie être une
puissance d' équilibre ça ne veut plus
rien dire cela n'a plus aucun sens
poutine lui même ne veut pas de la paix
ni de négociations
systématiquement depuis le début du
conflit conflit dont il est le seul et
unique responsable
ces demandes diplomatiques ont toujours
correspondu à ses objectifs militaires
maximum annexion de la crimée
indépendance de l'est séparatistes et
vassalisation du reste d'ukraine avec un
régime fantoche vous pourrez aussi dire
on n'a rien vu on comprend pas comment
poutine en arriver là votre fascination
pour les régimes forts vous à aveugler
sur la nature de cet homme la réalité
est que poutine a rasé la tchétchénie en
1999 avant l'ukraine il a fait subir le
même sort à la géorgie en 2008 soutien
aux séparatistes puis invasion du pays
il musèle la société civile russe depuis
des années les opposants politiques
finissent en prison pour des décennies
ce qu'il fait depuis le début de cette
guerre est juste a concentré de ces
vingt années de pouvoir votre
aveuglement est inquiétant pour des gens
qui prétendent à gouverner vous vous
prétendez conservateur patriotes
nationalistes souverainistes vous voulez
défendre et rendre leur grandeur la
france et à l'europe est dans tous les
cas vous êtes attachés à vos racines
votre pays et à sa culture le rôle du
conservateur et de rappeler que la
marche en avant ne doit pas faire
oublier ses racines être conservateur
s'est porté un regard critique sur
l'évolution de sa propre civilisation
mais restait attaché à celle ci c'est
vouloir qu'elle redevienne c'est qu'elle
a été du temps de sa grandeur or on ne
combat pas le déclin de sa culture en
faisant allégeance à une autre aux
valeurs en taïwan l'europe n'a jamais
été à l'image de ce qu'est la russie
depuis toujours pays autocratiques
instaurant le mensonge et la violence
contre son propre peuple en mode de
gouvernance normale en vous tournant
vers la russie plutôt que vers l'ukraine
non seulement vous tournez le dos un
peuple vaillant qui peut être un exemple
moral pour l'occident déclinant mais en
plus vous faites le choix de tourner le
dos à nos valeurs à notre histoire à
notre culture vous n'êtes pas loin et je
dis pas loin pour laisser une
possibilité de discussion vous n'êtes
pas loin d'être des traîtres à
l'occident
voilà donc ma position
pour le moins tranchées et rugueuse
vis-à-vis des droits tard plus ou moins
pro russe n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires à me dire quelle est votre
position parce que il me semble que ce
positionnement pro russe est très
répandue dans les milieux militants mais
qu'il ne correspond absolument pas à la
réalité de l'électorat de droite
bref sur ce et bien je dis en tout cas à
la prochaine